hello and welcome back to big mood
everybody
oh sexy it's very moody in here because
we're talking about celestial ash
things celeste
stress things um okay we're talking
about astrology today
astrology i'm so excited for this one
i know thank you i'm excited too but i'm
more excited though because we have
exactly that's what i was gonna say so
i'm kind of nervous
because this episode gets requested a
lot and i feel like it always gets
requested
at me because they're like oh nikki's
really into that [ __ ]
but i'm not like an expert at it okay me
neither yeah
so disclaimer like we're not experts
we're good experts okay we're into it
because well
enthusiasts yeah yeah enthusiastic
intermediate level i would even say
yeah for me yeah well great so we'll
just bounce back and forth
also i want a disclaimer because time
astrology gets brought up there's always
this sector of
haters that are like how dare you talk
about something not scientific and they
get very mad at you
and stuff and i'm like listen you need
to chill it's not that serious
um no one's like in a religion they're
trying to force on you
or convert you to no one's trying to use
it to argue
science okay we're just having fun okay
yeah and if you're into it you're into
it and if you're not into it
move the [ __ ] along because it's kind of
fun okay i'd like to like the video
first get anywhere
i like the video greatest greatest five
stars man i'm that person i'm just like
nikki you're being [ __ ] weird but at
the same time like yeah it's so fun
though i know it is fun when you get
called out you're like
oh oh my gosh is this true exactly
yeah it's like you know someone knows
secrets about you and you're like
dude the only time i have ever felt that
feeling that you just described stacy
was
actually from you really yes the only
time in my life i ever felt like that
was a sagittarius thing
because you're like you're just like my
sister is such a sagittarius thing and i
forgot
what did i do i don't remember you're
probably super blunt and honest
oh was it no no it was something about
me taking something literal
oh yeah for sure that's a such thing
for sure my mind blew i was like yeah
that's a thing yeah but i do and it's
not even
because of me it's because of the stars
i'm not gonna lie like i've seen some
things where i'm just like all right
calm down like on twitter or somebody
was like
oh it's [ __ ] if you take pictures
with your hand on your face
all the time that means you're a capri
sun and i'm just like you're [ __ ]
dumb dude
but you know caprice but you know
sometimes i like to read it and
sometimes you guys read me and i'm just
like oh
you know why i never really took it
serio like like
past me thinking like this is dumb is
because every time i read anything about
sagittarius
it almost never applied to me so i'm
like
this is dumb like this this makes no
sense it's either that or
it's extremely generic where i'm like
literally anyone can be this
well yes we will get to that first of
all you should make sure that
maybe you're not a sagittarius maybe
like your mom lied to you about your
birthday so
check out that oh yeah yeah make sure
you got the right birthday there i'm not
david
david he didn't have his proper birthday
and stuff because
oh [ __ ] yeah because he was born in
korea when he came they they added a
year
whatever also he don't remember anyone's
birthday i'm just put that out there
right now
that's old colin davis get over it
he's a nary that's such an aries thing
aries
i only know that because he told me he
was an aries and i was like i'm an aries
too
and then he was like yeah and then i was
like yeah you're angry you are an area
he wasn't angry too much angry man you
know i love aries women but aries guys
i'm always like
stop i've never dealt with it except for
david but like superficially
hmm yeah okay i guess i didn't really i
didn't realize see that too like
remembering
dates and then knowing people's signs
and then on top of that remembering what
traits each sign has i'm like that's
exhausting
okay so here's where i feel like people
take it too far when people
use it to be like oh i'm not going to
interact with you because you're that
side
yeah or that's like a religion yeah at
that point
exactly you're going too far into like
making this your
dogma um or when they're like well i
can't help it i'm a scorpio and that's
just what we do like you're
not letting your shitty behavior be
taken account on before like you're
you're just like letting it be up to the
stars that you are an [ __ ]
right okay so i don't like that i'm
putting that out there too
um but i wanted to know because whenever
this does get requested i wanted to know
what exactly is it that you guys are
interested in especially the ones
right here that are like i think it's
dumb like what what do you want to know
then
what interests you what interests you
about it for me personally i'm the most
curious to know like what like in a
general sense
what does my sign mean to people because
like i said every time that i have read
anything about my astrology it never
really applies to me so i'm like then
what is the general sense
of assad okay and gina
i i just like taking quizzes online
such a leo just kidding um
okay so if you want to play along i
think the most helpful thing for you to
do if you're watching you're listening
or
and if you're in the room too there's a
few resources out there you can get your
whole birth chart
i think having your whole birth chart
helps a lot more
than just like knowing your generic sign
because when you talk about like oh this
is too generic
yeah yeah it's because it's just giving
like the broad sense of your sun sign
usually
the ones in the magazines or the ones
that are like today you're going to find
a penny on the ground
that one's like it's your sun sign it's
it's not meant to be that specific there
you know which one is a specific one
okay so once you get
the plane i didn't even know there was
three different things i thought it was
just yours there's a whole chart there's
a hole
when you were born the stars were
aligned in a specific way that describes
you
so unique to you yes so the sun was at a
certain point the moon
jupiter venus everything mercury
specifically
all those planets there's 12 different
celestial bodies so all the planets and
then there's the sun and the moon
and a node and whatever that is um
uh but yeah so oh so the resources if
you
my favorite there's certain apps out
there that can give your whole birth
birth chart for free but you have to
know your the day
the date you were born um the year where
you were born the location you were born
at and your specific birth time because
that
als that influences your rising sign
which changes every two hours so
if you're off by a few hours it's gonna
significantly
change your birth chart so you gotta
know your birth time that should be on
your birth certificate
check your birth certificate ask your
parents figure that out it is on your
birth certificate
yeah for mine there you go and isaac
then you can go to an app
i there's a several different apps i
like co-star the best have you tried
co-star
no i haven't oh my god you want to try
it yeah same one i have
right here right here nice nicky rick i
think it's great because
it breaks down into layman's terms your
specific
thing so when i say like i'm not an
expert it's like i can't go into
specifically what a sagittarius is
because i didn't care enough to look up
sagittarius i'm not that so i'm like
no but then you you guys do tend to know
other science general things it feels
like you are an expert
because of that when you were saying
like oh my god like i
it's so overwhelming knowing everything
it's not even trying to memorize it it's
just that
you know certain like you start with
your family members
and then your partner and then yourself
and then you're like
oh you did do that or like you could
even tell on people's social media
like gina looks like a leo and through
like there's certain qualities
um they're like the they want to be the
queens the kings and queens
they're lame the king of the jungle
their hair um
like birthdays leo girls [ __ ] love
their birthdays like the whole month is
their birthday everybody knows it's
their birthday
leo does he love him is he not a leo
yeah she's like it's my [ __ ] birthday
[ __ ] like stop what you're doing
dj khaled okay
his life is all about him he's like then
i want you to win
yeah i uh i i'll read the leo thing and
i'm just like
i'm just almost like pissed like all
right yeah i guess you got something
right i suppose
and then i remember nikki said something
like she was explaining to
steve what a leah was and and then he
stops her halfway goes wait
is gina leo i think he's like yep but
he's like oh
i believe now describing like generally
and he was like funny
see that's what i want to know about
sagittarius that's so cute and then
there's certain things like
okay there's elements so uh there's
water signs
um scorpio pisces cancer or water
science they're more
emotional they might be a little bit
more guarded but they're like more on
the emotional
side of things ares leo and
sagittarius you're all fire signs you're
all fiery
you can just like let things go and
stuff and maybe you'll react we're
confrontational and we tend to be like
what are you going to talk about it or
not are we going to [ __ ] talk about
it
my sad recently came out that like this
past year yeah but then that really came
out
because now i'm like let's go yeah let's
talk about it then
your little beach why don't we go
through and list
all of our three signs and then we can
put it on the screen too
oh three oh because so there's the so
once you go to co-star enter
all your information so you can play
along with us so yeah we're not
responsible
you can also go to i think it's
astro.com or cafe astrology
those will give you your full birth
chart too so you can follow along
if you're not if you don't want to
download an app right now you can just
go on a computer
um but the three top things the ones
that affect you the most and the ones
that everyone talks about
are your sun sign that's the one you're
born in so you're sagittarius
everyone knows that leo um the moon sign
is the second one and that's your
emotions so
your truest self who you are to the
closest people around your soul you're
also a sach moon i saw oh
me too i'm a massage moon too if we name
out all three bryce can you list can you
put it on the screen in front of our
faces
so everyone can keep our star signs on
here put all three of them on us
we wear it on our face so when people
are like wait but what's your moon
so now you know you're also i'm double
double sad
fire girl double sag for that double vag
you know what i'm saying
right too like i don't know what does
that mean i got kids you know what i'm
saying you know
say all right and then the third one is
the third one is rising that's how you
present yourself to the world
that's what people say you have
ascending you're a pa sending is the
same as rising oh
um so that's when people first meet you
they see you as a pisces
oh what does that mean yeah so for
example when you guys first met me
you saw me as an aquarius very friendly
very outgoing very sweet
you know good things and then once you
get to know me like for example
my sister knows my moon sign that's my
sagittarius you know i tend to be very
straightforward very to the point
very direct you know and to people in
general i'm just
like an aries you know like overall you
have those
you're rising series no no my aquarius
is my racing oh
that's how like when i first meet people
and it's like oh hi how are you
like i'm a people person i'm very warm
like outgoing
entertainment you know so let me go over
our archetypes then
now that we know he's an archetype now
well each sign has an
archetype so for you tiff your son
in the best way that if okay i heard
this one sentence that makes it make
so much sense and if you're playing
you're just letting your logic mind go
just like [ __ ] let it go
play along with us so it's gonna get
woo-woo okay
astronomy is like the study of the
science parts if you're into that go
study the celestial bodies and get all
the facts astrology's more like the
poetry the art the like
how it resonates with you and how you
engage in the world okay
and the best sentence i heard for
incorporating these three
elements um is you take your your sun
sign and you're like so
i am a blank with the soul of a
blank is your moon sign wearing the mask
of a blank is your rising sign
so for me i'm a scorpio so
scorpio's archetype is um the detective
or the sorcerer or the hypnotist so
i am a sorcerer with the soul of a
also scorpio with the soul of a
detective um and then my rising is
gemini that's how people see me
it's performer it's more um
the sign for it um but it's like you
know communications
the teacher the story or the storyteller
that kind of thing so
i'm a sorcerer with the soul of a
detective
wearing the mask of a teacher or wearing
the mask of a storyteller i feel like
we're about to play some dungeons and
dragons right now
yeah i'm gonna bring my dice out except
it's life yeah
yeah i'm like staring at that artwork
behind you because it has like all the
signs
yeah that's what your birth chart kind
of looks like all the signs are on the
outside like that
and then you got the water fire air
earth
that's like that's exactly what it looks
like except you're going to have planets
in your
oh we have it here too yeah i just spent
my life angry that my leo sign looks
like a [ __ ] sperm
of the m no i don't know the circle with
the [ __ ] tail i see it now
yeah it does look like a sperm that's
nice it's cute
he's like that's not a disguise
sagittarius archetypes are um the gypsy
the student wait the gypsy like does
that mean like psychic like i can
yeah remember like you with the crystal
ball on the um on the
jk yeah that jk
that too so yeah you you have that in
your sun and your moon so gypsy student
philosopher
and then your rising was what oh
yes pisces so two sad and one pisces so
that
um archetype is like i'm ordering
mcdonald's is uh the mystic the dreamer
the poet
the face dancer you're just all mystical
oh yeah so you're my i'm always
concerned with like
we'll get into is it good or is it bad
that's
you and you were aries aries
no no airy sag aries sad aquarius
aquarius
so aries archetypes are the warrior the
pioneer
the daredevil the survivor yeah yes
[ __ ]
period i love it sagittarius is your
moon
is the gypsy the student the philosopher
and then the mask is aquarius which is
the genius the revolutionary
the truth sayer the scientist the exile
wow yeah that's how the world sees you
yeah
yeah yeah i'm like i live in the essence
of my birth truth
in my birth chart i love that every time
i see you tweet i'm like yes
i don't even got to read the whole thing
i'm just like yeah
what's your what's you do you have leo
as your son what's your moon
and rising i am uh my my moon is in
taurus
ascendant is in scorpio okay
that makes sense okay
so your leo is your son so you are the
king
the queen the performer the child
the clown does it really say that yeah
this is the clown but like
i would take that as more like the
performer like
the clown slap yeah there we go the king
queen
i see you as like the queen cause a
picture of you with the oh yeah tiara on
and then your um moon was horse
taurus so with the soul of the earth
spirit
the musician the silent one oh that is
casey because casey
is a tourist oh yeah gina's not the
silent one yeah
she is when you try to hang out with her
when you're not working yeah and that's
like her closest yes
oh so yeah yeah i'm pretty much am i
saying so let's see her aquarius
i mean her rising scorpio scorpio rising
so
people with my mask right yeah this is
like at work wearing the mask of the
detective the sorcerer the hypnotist
she's horny
passionate stubborn resourceful st
stubborn is what i
recognize his name yeah notorious is
stubborn right
yeah that's right yeah yeah
okay so those are the three most
important things like when
people are discussing astrology and
people are like
okay like that's your son but what's
your rising what's your moon you're like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
that's what they're talking about that's
what like what are you presenting to the
world or what is how do you handle your
emotions
and that's what i like that's what i
personally like astrology for is like
it's a different
conversation tool it's like if you're in
the game and you're playing with the
rules and stuff you get to like
have different types of conversations
it's like oh that makes sense
you do this and blah blah blah i like
that stuff because it feels like someone
knows me without knowing it yeah
especially if you're a scorpio i have no
this has happened to me so many times
because for some reason all scorpios
tend to be into
astrology for some reason every scorpio
[ __ ] i've ever met
has been into the fact that they're a
scorpio and so
when i like had to show my id certain
places
like if they're carting me somewhere or
whatever um
several times if it's a girl carting me
she's like scorpio i'm a scorpio and
then we do a little high five
like it's like a secret club
that is cute and like i hate that i know
that i hate that i like this too
it's like having vip membership at
starbucks you're like damn i hate that i
i do have vip membership i have a gold
card
i hate that i like this a corporate
[ __ ]
okay so now that you have your birth
chart too uh when you're
reading your birth chart if you want to
go all into this and this is just stuff
that i recently learned
um there's a book called uh what is this
book i wanna
tell you about it there's this book
called the inner sky
by stephen forrest that breaks down a
lot of this and i
like recently watched a video of someone
kind of giving me the cliff notes on it
but i
i ordered the book because of that video
so i know a little bit more but i'm
not an expert okay but here's how you
read your birth chart so the first thing
you're going to look at is the planets
right
so where your planets align in your
birth chart and each planet
represents a different what like what
uh what it like yeah i know that venus
is beauty yeah exactly
like that kind of thing and then mars is
communication you got
the sun which is your ego your core self
your center personality
you got the moon which is like your
feelings your emotion your sensitivity
you got mercury which is intelligence
mind thinking logic
god she's the smart one in sailor moon
mercury
yeah i'm intelligent so cute that is
cute it's really cool
venus is the beauty the harmony the
creativity
the love um so whenever you hear about
these planets being in retrograde when
people are like
mercury retrograde like what does that
mean like it's because that is going
it appears to be going backwards in the
sky which makes
the things that it's controlling go
backwards like it's not as good as
controlling those things anymore so when
venus for example the planet of beauty
and harmony and love is in retrograde
it's making all of those things
not work so well here on earth so if you
want to
get your boobs done during venus
retrograde
probably going to have a botched boob
job just be ready for that like
anything that enhances your beauty might
not go as planned
for you when venus is in retrograde if
you want your teeth fixed
maybe you should order candid at a time
when venus is not in retrograde and i
think right now
venus is not in retrograde at all
tonight feel free
to go order candid who is sponsoring us
today on today's episode
candid is the place where you want to go
when you want to smile quick
okay you want a good smile but you're
like i don't want to wait three years
for braces like i had to do in high
school with the rubber bands and then
don't wear your retainer it comes back
no you're like i need a
my teeth straight now because i got to
get those pics in and i don't know how
to use face tune
okay so candid clear aligners are
comfortable
removable and totally invisible unlike
wire braces where you put the little
clear rubber bands yellow blending in
now
nope oh it turns all yellow when you get
the white one what did i think that
would work
with clear braces because that's what i
did really
yeah doesn't work but these are
completely totally invisible so you can
transform your smile without anyone
noticing
you just lost normally oh yeah with
candid because they're removable
oh yeah i was like how did they get
through the thing oh yeah because you
remove it okay
so your treatment is also prescribed and
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist who's an
expert in tooth movement not some random
person
giving you bad advice it's a licensed
orthodontist
with candid your treatment includes
remote monitoring by the same
orthodontist who created your plan so
you never have to wonder how you're
doing you'll always know
we love that the average candid
treatment is just six months you'll
start seeing results way before then and
costs an
average of 50 less than invisalign
so think about it before you order so if
you're ready to take the first step
towards getting your dream smiling can't
wait to show it off get started today
from the comfort of your own home with
canada's risk-free starter kit and 75
dollars off
go to candidco.com
mood and use code mood that's candid
co.com
mood code mood for your risk free
starter kit
and 75 doll hairs off
candidco.com mood code
mood and then doll hairs
so uh we have stitch fix here because
for all you people who are lazy and
don't want to go shopping
stitch fix is a personal stylist that um
picks out clothing for you wouldn't you
love if every clothing store you shopped
at
already understood your loves hates and
total no-go zones like for me
i was gonna say i don't wear pink but i
have like one pink thing
it's so cute though it's blush here it
is
well there's a company that will choose
your clothing for you you go online you
take a quiz and you tell them what you
like
me i just say black all across the board
and they send you a box of clothing and
accessories
shoes even that you might like and then
you could also select an
option to be like oh i want to be more
adventurous so usually
gina will wear nothing but black but if
she decides to be adventurous
the stylist would be like you know what
you'll look good in this and then you
get to try it out
to get started all you have to do is set
up your profile and it'll deliver great
looks personalized just for you
in your colors style and budget you pay
a 20
styling fee for each fix which is
credited towards anything that you keep
so if you end up keeping something the
20
goes to that schedule at any time
there's no subscription required plus
shipping returns and exchanges are easy
and free
yeah they give you the bag and
everything you just put it in there and
send it back
um stitch fix does the hard work for you
making great styles effortless for
everybody including women
men and kids nice yeah
uh get started today at stitchfix.com
mood
mood and you'll get 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix that's
mood mood for 25 off when you keep
everything
in your fix once again that is
stitchfix.com
all right back to the planets everybody
uh
venus beauty harmony creativity i don't
know how interesting this is for all of
you but
here's the reason why these are
important is because where they are in
your chart
is how your chart gets more specific
and catered to you and not so generic
like how you hate
because it's like oh when you were born
mercury was in this house and all this
stuff so
this is what each planet means um
jupiter
is about faith vitality confidence
did i say mars was about aggression in a
certain way
sorry mars don't get aggressive
uh mars is about like will aggression
assertiveness freedom independence
self-determination god of war yes oh
yeah
yeah i said earlier that mars is
communication but i meant that for
mercury
mercury yes um jupiter is about
confidence expansiveness generosity
cheerfulness oh yeah so when jupiter is
in retrograde
like your money gets tighter anyway
it's not i have literally never heard of
anything else in retrograde but
mercury and venus i've never heard of
any other planets venus in retrograde
yeah until recently
recently yeah the problem with when the
other planets go retrograde is they stay
retrograde for a lot longer than mercury
but we don't feel it as heavy as mercury
because
mercury and venus are closer to us than
other planets
that's why they're more important yeah
so they don't you ever feel those
effects they see
like do you ever feel like when the
planets are in retrograde and you're
like oh
yeah this is definitely i don't i i
think i follow too much like astrology
on all my social medias because i always
see something going in retrograde
so i don't even read into it because
then i feel like if i know about it i'm
gonna be like oh
no yeah it's like this is all going
wrong yeah you don't want to say this
yeah yeah i just i try not to think
about it and like especially because
when
mercury is going to go in retrograde
everyone is like oh no mercury's gotta
go retrograde and i'm like oh [ __ ] we're
all [ __ ]
let's just all stop everything we're
doing but
um yeah i don't really like to look too
deep into it
because i'm like well whatever's gonna
happen is gonna happen and i just have
to deal with it yeah
you have to kind of approach it that way
i think that it's a good like
if you want to like think about it as
like a warning thing i liked using them
as reminders but not necessarily
something to control my life so
um like you should be extra careful when
reviewing things anyway right but we
always kind of go through life and we're
like whatever
well mercury's retrograde it's like a
reminder to be like hey
look through your [ __ ] carefully and
it's like oh yeah i should be doing that
anyway
so it's kind of like that feeling with
your color color
exactly so i have a color thing too
because i'm into numerology as well
okay you know i'll arrange anything
we're not gonna go into numerology today
but
uh i wanna do that we could do a
different episode of numerology
but yeah every day is a different color
and each color represents something
according to the date you were born in
your own personal numerology and
it's just a reminder for me it's like on
a red day it's a new beginnings day i'm
like
i'm gonna look for all the new
beginnings today and it's not like dogma
i'm not like i have to find a new
beginning today
but it's just like a fun thing um so
people always talk about mercury
retrograde and i don't know if you want
to talk about this now or maybe i'll go
through the planets and talk about it
let's talk about it now because we're
already on it but it's not necessarily a
bad thing you just have to be
um so anything that has to do with like
that starts with re like
review redecorate re-pair
like things like that i mean something
again it's actually it helps that
aspect of it because it's what mercury
in retrograde means is to go back
and fix something that should have been
done properly the first time instead of
starting something new
yeah and so if you start something new
it it probably isn't going to go bad it
might or it might
go bad according to you know astrology
um it's better to go back and fix
something new or reunions like
um old relationships that maybe never
got closure a lot of people
find closure during that period of time
so there's a lot of positive that comes
from
a mercury retrograde and regrets
go back and review your regrets and
repair them yeah i wonder what's the
history of astrology like who
decided i'm glad you brought that up
perfect
so the ancient babylonians
oh okay at one time it was regarded as
the science but that was because you
know like we're all bored and trying to
make sense of life
maybe not even bored but you're just
like what's the point of my being right
right we're all kind of doing that still
but back then they didn't have a lot to
go off of they didn't have the internet
they didn't have a lot of research and
studies they didn't have a lot of
science and hardcore facts and things
that have been proven yet so
they started studying the sky and they
noticed that
um well one seasons like it's colder
when these stars are in the sky
and it's warmer during when these stars
are in the sky so when you see
like the signs um they're like oh when
it when this star
signed cancer they they made stories so
that
they could remember this when the stars
were in the sky because it would take a
full year for them to see it again
so they're like when that's in the sky
it's warmer it's the start of summer and
so that's kind of how our calendar year
started was by them recognizing that
there's
certain stars in the sky and
constellations and creating months to go
by it
there's a whole bunch of redos on the
calendar
after a while probably because they did
it during mercury retrograde am i right
yeah yeah cause i heard that there was
like a whole another sign that
apparently is now a new sign oh yeah and
if you're born after 2009 i guess like
all the
signs are shifted so i don't know i
can't keep up
guys but look it up for yourself if it
doesn't have to do with 1986 and
and scorpio then i didn't look it up
okay
but um but yeah back then they they
would study that there was also
um so then so people went by that for a
while because they would kind of predict
things that would happen they would
notice certain patterns of people being
born under
those signs acting certain ways so they
kind of started creating generalizations
then also um medical doctors
before there was advanced medicine back
then if you had an ailment
they would just like kind of treat it on
the spot they'd be like
oh your arm's shitty like take this this
this and this and they didn't really
record anything
but the astrology doctors they did start
recording things because they wanted to
know in depth like everything
like when were you born and they would
chart it to the stars and even though
their diagnosis maybe wasn't that
accurate from the stars that was the
beginning of recorded medical history
which they still
use today like they look at your history
now before they prescribe you something
and that was the first
record of doctors actually doing that
and it actually provided a lot of
information that helped them
properly diagnose people in the future
um so that's really cool
and like there's a lot of little things
left over that were started
back then by astrologers but basically
it's all
it's all uh centered around the earth
being the center of the universe earth
so
when they discovered that it wasn't um
it kind of made their
theories and things fall apart and
there's a lot that's not
proven obviously it's not hard science
um and then when isaac newton came along
i was like what [ __ ] it up he was like
yo i think
actually physics could explain a lot of
this and then he had like some pretty
good evidence to support that and then
science started switching over and they
were like
[ __ ] astrology and then there was like
one last astrologer that was like
no this is the science and he got pretty
misproven in court and so that they like
all the other scientific community like
made a laughingstock out of him and then
and then um anyone that tries to make it
actual science now gets
you know laughed at but because i did
discover it through
costar like when i was putting in my
info into that app
it ended up saying that they go based
off of a specific
type of astrology and i didn't even know
there were other types oh
like what i didn't know there were other
types either yeah like
in the settings it's like we go i'll
look it up we can continue but it
literally says in the settings like we
go based off of this
type and then there's the asian ones too
like i'm a snake
what are you guys oh yeah i'm a tiger
how sweet
i forgot the the chinese astrology
yeah the house system what's your year
91.
when i was little there was this chinese
restaurant in in mexico where we would
go eat and they had the calendar like on
the
oh yeah yeah i'm a what goat greatest of
all time
oh [ __ ] sounds like me mm-hmm were you
91 91 you were 90. 89. also you're a
snake too
yes i'm also a sam you're a young ass
[ __ ]
i'm not that young probably people
listening are way younger than me yeah
yeah if you're not that young what am i
yeah we're just we're not that young but
we're at a plane that is
beautiful i like it better now than when
i was young you're 100
correct yeah did you ever actually go
based off of
certain things because of astrology like
when you were growing up
so it's so so right now when you were
talking about it and you're like oh like
people that are into australia you get
laughed at and stuff i was thinking and
i was like man there's people that make
so much money from me
and like laughing to the bank you know
what i mean
at that point who cares who's laughing i
i think it's
we're very fortunate to be born in a
time and live in a time where
people can have different ideas and
people can believe in different things
and maybe like i don't know if it's
because we live here but even when i
lived in mexico it was very common
for people to know like your sun sign
and like oh what are you and like i grew
up being an aries and i always knew that
any do you remember uh walter marcotte
yes
yes so okay so in spanish staple and
yeah in spanish tv
there's this guy named uh or there was
this guy named
no no he's still alive what yeah netflix
just made a documentary about him
mandela effect gotcha
yeah netflix literally everyone was like
rest in peace
they just made a documentary about him
yeah look he died
he's dead that's what i'm like rest in
peace
is finding out he died you i think you
just found out he died
oh no that is so sad yes okay well he's
alive in her heart okay
yeah he's like he's a uh
i'm gonna say he is until i get proof
that he passed away
is he dead girl he passed november of
2019.
oh so recently i mean like within the
past year
i know when i saw this i literally like
my heart stopped for a little bit and i
was like
yes so basically he was this guy who
tried to be an actor
in spanish he's puerto rican he was
puerto rican and
he was really into astrology so he would
tell people like oh you're a scorpio
this this and that and like onset
right yeah and then when people were
like oh that is so interesting like hey
we need five minutes to fill the morning
show can you just do that real quick on
tv this guy you've seen him mm-hmm
he's fabulous yeah she is so fabulous
and this isn't a time where like being
gay wasn't acceptable right yeah
so they're like can you we have 10
minutes to fill the morning show can you
just like do it on tv and he was like
oh like aries you're doing this and leo
you're doing that today and like he was
always just very flamboyant in a time
where that wasn't accepted
in the 80s 90s and everybody started
calling the
the network and being like we love him
like we want to see him tomorrow like we
need that of him and so he grew super
successful and ended up with his one
hour show
eventually just doing astrology for an
hour on spanish tv
which in sp like well in hispanic
culture catholicism is like
super strong and so he was the one
person that was doing something
different
so i thought of him when you say like
well people were laughing at astrologers
and i'm like he made so much money from
that
you know and also um the so there's a
part of my brain when i'm like okay what
like what part of this
because there's a lot of like accuracies
where i'm like well like what made
someone come up with that then but when
you look at like how like the moon
influences the tide and stuff and you
look at how everything in the universe
came from the same place right like
everything's made of the same matter and
everything any matter that ever existed
is in the universe
and so we all came from there and and
then each thing influences another
thing in the universe right and anything
that's closest to you is influencing you
more
than the things farther away so the moon
is the closest to us it influences our
tides it influences women's
menstrual cycles it influences yeah yeah
what you have a cycle like the moon and
that's and that's
proven like that actually is
scientifically proven it does affect
that so
and we what affects it like what's
making the moon like it's an energy or i
don't know what it is scientifically
speaking
but it's affecting us so if you look at
how the things in the sky
and the energy there is affecting you
then it's not in
it's not far as far-fetched to believe
that when you were born the things
the things that were in the sky and that
were closest to the earth at that time
maybe it affected you and like on a
subconscious level
well and even the way you're saying it
like everything is energy that's a
scientific fact that's physics energy is
energy
right and we are all energy cannot stop
existing
so even me pushing this you get pushed
and then eventually something happens
and the energy keeps transmitting
over and over and over so it's the same
thing
with the energy that the stars and the
moon gave you at whatever point
i always think why not believe in it if
it hasn't been proven
wrong and yeah it's fun that's what i'm
where i'm at too
yeah and so it's more fun to believe it
than to not believe it especially when
no one knows like
you don't know where you go when you die
you don't know if life just ends or if
there's something else you don't know if
your soul goes back to a source you
don't know
you don't know anything you definitely
the people that turn off
people from astrology are those hardcore
ones
that are like yeah like the like you're
saying earlier it's like oh
euro whatever i don't want to be friends
with you i was gonna say
i think those people are actually not
the hardcore people because as a
hardcore
astrology believer i'm gonna name myself
i understand that you have a whole chart
you're not just a sagittarius
you are all of the signs to some degree
you want to be hardcore
yeah they want to be hardcore that's
like your scorpio period like oh my god
i can't deal with you like okay well
then you obviously don't know what
you're talking about because there's so
many faces to a person
and so many things that are different
about them you know so
i don't think those are the true
hardcore people i think those are
probably the people that are
maybe just had a bad experience and now
they're like
labeling everyone who's the same sign
under that
right true i think it's a fun date thing
when you date someone new like what's
your sign
and you guys read it together yeah
that's always fun when you get into a
chart oh my god oh you're going to be
like
what's your everything exactly what time
asked your mom what time you were born
and i need to see your birth chart
your birth certificate because she's
lying oh [ __ ] yeah
like that i'm not like that
of like the other things the planets
where they are and like oh yeah because
yeah the app ends up telling me like
capricorn and venus or i don't know what
else and then there's the houses
that are the what area of life that it's
affecting
the app is they go based off of a house
system yeah so
so yeah your first house is the house of
personality it's your identity your
social identity your appearance the
second house is a house of money
so it's your self-esteem money
possession self-respect
the third is the house of communication
it's your information gathering
so let's say you have like mars is in
your communication and it's always like
aggressive communication
or let's say your stomach's in
hellofresh because they sponsored our
show today and let's sign hellofreshes
we should tweet at them and ask them
hopefully an earth sign we can find out
organic what time the company was made
so hello fresh if you enjoy healthy
meals and you
want to cook them but you're like i
don't know how to cook or make my meals
pretty
hello fresh is for you it's delicious
they offer like so many recipes to
choose from each week i like that they
have specific diets too that you can
like request and they only have to size
they have
different sizes family packs and family
sizes for yourself
single very single people
jess uh he saves you time hello fresh
cuts out stressful meal planning
and grocery store trips you can enjoy
cooking and get dinner on the table in
just about 30 minutes or even 20 minutes
with their quick recipe options
sustainable hello fresh
pre-portioned ingredients means there's
less prep for you and less food waste
and they give back okay hello fresh
donated over 2.5 million meals to
charity in 2019 and this year is
stepping up their food donations amid
the coronavirus crisis
so i personally love their salads i've
never really been a salad person but i
tried this one bomb ass salad that i
can't remember the exact name of right
now but it was like it was a cotija
sound oh my god i could eat a whole
block of that yeah it's so good i don't
even really eat
cheese but if you want to see for
yourself you could try out america's
number one meal kit go to
hellofresh.com 80 big mood and use code
80 big mood that's 8-0 big mood to get a
total of
80 off including free shipping on your
first box
additional restrictions restrictions
apply
please visit hellofresh.com for more
details again go to hellofresh.com
eight zero big mood and use code 80 big
mood to get a total of eighty dollars
off including free shipping on your
first box
additional restrictions apply please
visit hellofresh.com for more details
that's right and as you're enjoying your
hello fresh meal
how about you keep yourself entertained
with a fun and exciting puzzle game
like best fiends which is a mobile
puzzle game app
and guys you guys know how much i love
best fiends i've been addicted to this
game for many years now
and i'm proud to say that and what this
game is
it like i said has it's a unique and
exciting
puzzle game so you it ends up feeling
like a brain exercise a little bit
because you have to
use these little these adorable cute
little fiends these little characters
that each fiend ends up having like a
special power that helps you
finish that puzzle so you have to kind
of like play around with which
fiends would actually be best for you to
defeat those slugs and then they have
these
beautiful beautiful graphics like the
the actual
because you know mobile app games they
usually have like kind of crappy like
graphics it's like oh this is just an
app but no
best fiends they are it's really
beautiful graphics and also they update
their app
all the time so they have like uh
different events
for the particular times of the year and
so they're constantly keeping
the app updated which means i never get
bored of this app
so best fiends has thousands of levels
already with new levels events and
characters added every month it's hours
of fun right at your fingertips and you
can even play offline which is my
favorite thing ever because sometimes
you don't have
service and during those times it's
perfect because you can still play
offline
with over 100 million downloads and tons
of five star reviews best fiends is a
must
play download best fiends free on the
apple
app store or google play that's friends
without the r
fiends best fiends yay you think of me
when you play
so i was gonna go through all the houses
but it's pretty boring and i don't think
you're gonna retain all that information
the things that i found that were most
interesting though
on the birth chart that i didn't know
before maybe you knew this before but
did you know that like if when you look
at the birth chart like that circle like
this
and it's going to be in like different
quadrants if your
planets and you'll see like all these
different planets um if they're
mostly in the northern hemisphere that
means you'll deal with a lot of your
growth and like problems and things that
you have to all your lessons that you're
going through
more publicly like in in the public eye
and if you didn't know that yeah and if
the planets are in the southern
hemisphere
then you'll deal with your growth more
privately didn't know that
mine are probably way at the top mine
were
for sure how do you find out um it's in
your birth chart
wait but like i need my bird charm
charts you want to use my phone like but
where but like where
i don't think um coast coast oh they
don't have the chart chart
but if you go to um cafe astrology
or astro.com you gotta look at this yeah
you can actually see
the actual chart your chart chart
then also um if your planets are
more on the left side um you
live more like a freedom life like free
will
and then if they're more on the right
side it's more fate based
not saying that you don't have free will
but just a lot of things were destiny
whereas uh the left side everything is
more
like a blank canvas like you can create
is it the whole
life side because then you could be on
the southern left yeah so
public right yeah so private yeah
private
and yeah exactly private private fate or
public
i'm public kind of well more on the fate
well you'd have to middle you'd have to
see your chart where all the planets are
but when you're not into it like i'm
sure we didn't just start and we were
like we knew anything
you know it was like oh i'm an airy sun
cool and then it was like
why am i like this and then you like
kept looking and kept looking i actually
got
um reached out by an astrologer so she
reached out to me she followed me
and she was like what's your like what
are your main three and i was like i
have no idea what you're talking about
she's like what time were you born
and i told her and she was like oh my
god that makes so much sense
and then i was like oh really cool and
then this was like a while back
her name's diana and so she her
instagram is one love astrology
so she was like oh can we like i want to
read your birth chart like you have such
an interesting
birth chart and i would love for you to
get to know yourself better and i was
like
sure like yes let's do it and
i was so shook because she actually does
this for work right so
you can hire her and she'll read you
your birth chart like what it means to
you and stuff
you can do it but like this is what she
does and
i have it on my youtube channel like she
read the whole thing
and like expressed everything and i was
like why did you reach out and she's
like well when i follow people and like
i'm interested because
there's like their life story or this or
that like
i want to know more about them and it's
funny because until this day we kind of
became friends
till this day like well i'll say
something on one of my vlogs where i'll
be like oh my mom used to sell gold when
like
my parents divorced to put like food on
the table and stuff
she like reached out to me and she was
like that makes so much freaking sense
because you're this thing or that and
like
your mom selling the gold and this it
just it's crazy how in-depth astrology
can get and how much of a life story it
can say
wow you're probably on the fate side
yeah i mean yeah and
the the cool thing is like it's not
necessarily like oh it's truth
or it's a complete lie it's more of a
road map
of who you are meant to be by the stars
and if you follow that and you feel it
and you fulfill that
you're gonna feel an alignment with
yourself so for example i feel
in true alignment with my birth chart
like i
feel like i'm on the right path like
with my career with my love life with
myself and because of that i
i don't feel out of place you know so
when you see what you might have trouble
with
you you think to yourself well in my
birth chart says i might have trouble
with communicating in relationships
so that you can go out and like seek
therapy because you know you'll have
that trouble yeah
you can kind of have a roadmap of how to
make your life a little bit easier oh
that's cool
yeah and and i think what got me really
into it because like you when i first
read the generic descriptions i was like
that's not me like it's always like
scorpio you're so
you're like mysterious you're obsessed
with sex and death
and i'm like what i don't even like
those things
at all and then like later like going
more into depth i was like oh i like
this aspect of my sexuality and like
this i'm fascinated by not death but
like
what happens like what happens after
death or like
you know what what what can certain what
do certain religions believe and like i
was more fascinated with that than like
the actual like death part
yeah and then also death and tarot cards
and
and symbolism is like rebirth it's like
you end a certain part of your life or a
certain chapter and you're good at like
starting new chapters
so i almost always get the death card
whenever whenever someone reads my cards
they're like new cycle rebirth
wow i'm like all right well there you go
i had a tarot card reading late random
or reading recently
yeah what did it say um this girl that
she she's a fan that reached out on
twitter she's like i do tarot card
reading that's how it starts girl and
then you become friends with them and
then you're like
you have a tarot card reading tell me
more right
yeah she's like well i'm a beginner i'm
like a [ __ ] whatever it's three in
the morning [ __ ] let's do it yeah and it
was fun like it was it's just something
that's fun
um she's like well give me three
questions you can be vague or whatever
and then i'll see what the cards pull
for you and this is what the spirits
feel
she's like i have to like meditate first
and the spirits will come to me and
they'll help me pull the cards for you
that was that was cool
that's awesome yeah i wanna i wanna go
to like a a person
yeah reach out to my friend diana yeah
i'll tell her to reach out to you she's
so cool and she's so knowledgeable i
love her
when you say like i'll tell her reach
out to you i think she's going to appear
in a smoke
no she's actually like a real person
like she
literally she's really knowledgeable
though and i love her because she was
like i want to be like walter mercado
and then i was like [ __ ] yes like
pursue your dreams
yeah and there's certainly certain
religions that get kind of
you know iffy about tarot cards and
spirits and stuff because
yes like for me i don't know this is
kind of i don't know if it's
superstitious or because i was raised
catholic or whatever i can't do the
ouija board i feel like there's like
something negative it's very like
yeah dark there's a darkness in it and
then i'm like
it's a little scary i did it once when i
was like uh 10.
we had like me and my cousins we had a
ouija board that was tense the only
thing i don't think the spirits play
with kids but i'm sorry go ahead oh
that's fine
i mean it didn't matter because the only
thing i asked was am i going to be
taller than my cousin sandy
yes i am taller than her [ __ ] you sandy
was like let me just get in here really
quick yeah yeah
this birds are like
this word's like if i get here you're 10
years old just here what experts want to
mess with kids because they're easier to
like
i think kids are cute i mean pure you
know
i mean they could be but like when you
think about all the kids who have
imaginary friends
i think that those are spirits oh i
tried i couldn't
i couldn't someone won i couldn't either
i mean
you wanted one go that way an imaginary
friend
oh
well you know the crazy thing is when
you speak speaking you guys i'm breaking
down your site
speaking come back sorry it's cause
you're talking about
no somebody experience i believe in that
i'm talking about imaginary friends okay
well the speaking tungsten is like a
christian thing too so then that's where
like christianity and like
spirituality kind of collide and it gets
a little bit blurry because it's like
how do you believe in speaking in
tongues
you know because i'm personally someone
that considers
herself like spiritual and christian
like i do believe in god
and i don't know like i sometimes wonder
to myself like
what do i really believe in but i always
pray
and i always say to myself and to my god
like
everything that i question and every
like turret reading every astrology like
guide me
closer to you you know like if it's a
terror reading
let it be you that's speaking to me and
that way like i'm closer to it and it's
a way of communication that way you know
instead of like a random spirit dropping
in and being like
all right where are we feeling today you
know what i mean like the intention
she's pissed oh man
that's
at least when you set the intention and
you're like this is the one spirit
the highest spirit i believe in that i
want to channel then that way you're
more
in tune with it you know because i get
it all the time like in my comments when
i talk about it they're like
well don't you believe in like god
because i'm also very vocal about the
fact that i'm grateful for everything i
have
and i don't think you have to explain
yourself to anyone but
getting in depth about my personal
beliefs i do believe that
these are all tools you can use in order
to understand yourself better in order
to have a closer relationship
with your higher power yeah yeah and for
me it's like
if you read your birth chart and it
resonates with you isn't that awesome
like you
just had some self-discovery and you're
like i do do that oh i should work on
that
you know that's really cool and if it
doesn't resonate with you then then [ __ ]
it
like you didn't lose anything exactly
you didn't lose anything i think if it
doesn't resonate with you you have
the wrong yeah
when i was little i used to think i was
a like i got separated from my twins so
maybe i got my twins
this [ __ ] is like summoning
i'm summoning my twin that died at birth
i do
um photo what you have a photo talked
about this before it's a photo they did
like a photo effect to make two of me
from all my crap
my baptism photos maybe that's what they
told you that's what they told me
because one dress
laps over the other dress so i'm like
that's proof i have a twin out there i
know i do
my mom swears that i don't i think
you're pretty like out there on the
internet she'll find you
or she's or she's looking over you
somewhere oh no
you're an imaginary friend i mean she
didn't come to me
the other one's too more aside to me
because your mom just abandoned her oh
that is sad okay maybe she's looking
over you anyway if she exists
the last thing i wanted to talk about
because i was like um i don't know if
you know this one
this was new to me uh was the nodes do
you know the nodes
yeah i'm a little bit familiar but only
cause anna told me not because i know
okay but i think i'm in the north node
okay so you have a no
everyone has a north and south no oh
just kidding yeah i'm like
like on your birth chart sometimes they
only show you one but the other one is
180 degrees from it so that's what sign
it's in
but basically wherever your north and
south nodes are
your south node is where you came from
like what comes naturally to you
who you are as a child who you were
since birth you know that's who you
that's where you came from your north
node is where you should aspire to be to
have the most growth so from going from
south to north
is the most growth you could achieve in
your life so for me
personally and you'll just have to look
at your birth chart for yours but
my south nodes where i came from is in
libra
which means it's um like the peacemaker
the lover the artist right it looks like
a natural
like peace harmony balance that kind of
thing so that's like been there done
that
if i want to stay there that's cool you
just won't achieve that much growth
my north node is actually an aries so
it's the warrior the pioneer courage
will
fighter fierce and i'm like that's true
i do lack a backbone a lot of the times
like
it's hard for me to like stand up and
fight you know and like
be a warrior so it was just something to
think about because i had never heard
that before i never even like
noticed there was a nose
yeah you should also reach out to diana
especially because you like it i'll i'll
introduce you to hershey okay do you
guys want to see
diana in an episode yeah right honestly
you should she will like
school all of us she knows everything
and like she'll literally be like give
me your birth charts before we
even start and then she'll be all of you
she watches this episode she's like
that's cute
[ __ ] you should have just called me
like what are you doing today we were
bringing in babylonians and [ __ ] put me
on speakerphone right now
that's awesome yeah but i mean i think
it's fun and i do
even like seeing the similarities in
your friendships
for example like uh my girlfriends the
ones i hang out with the most like we're
all into this
so reading and seeing their birth charts
and seeing how they align with mine and
how we
all have a role in each other's lives
and the friendship
it's really interesting to think about
because it makes sense like we all have
partners too yeah for sure like my
boyfriend is a water sign
i don't know his rising because he
doesn't want to tell me his birth time
his yeah his family doesn't believe in
this is he asian
uh no he's mexican so there's a chinese
superstition
that or like it comes from feng shui but
it's basically like you should never
give
anyone all of your birth chart details
because then they can control your life
or they can
hold something over your fate and
destiny and stuff
yeah so there's there's that i don't
have people in my family
like like she this she took something
that belonged to one of my family
members as like a
like an object of their possession wrote
down all their birthdays yeah some
voodoo
that's black magic yeah she was crazy
and she in it she cast a spell it's
coming to her times three then
yeah right and she and she tried to like
oh why don't you come over and visit me
like not today satan no
thank you please yeah she's crazy well
anyway what were you saying about your
boyfriend
oh yeah well he's a water sign okay and
so for example me knowing that he's a
water sign
he is very in tune with his emotions he
is very much
able to communicate his feelings
and things that me as a fire sign would
be like are you kidding me like that's
what bother you
he's like yes and this is really painful
and we should talk about it and so i
as a fire sign have to sit down and be
like okay let's talk about it
let's introduce this like because i know
that about him
i know how to treat not treat him but
like how to cater to his feelings
to communicate better yeah instead what
if i was dealing with another fire sign
or if i was dealing with someone else
like my sister she's another fire sign
her and i we go at it not
disrespectfully but just like
i told you to do this i told you that
blah blah all right then bye and like i
know she can handle the heat that way
where the heat yeah as opposed to my
boyfriend he's like why are you being so
rude and mean and i'm like i'm literally
just talking
you know what's a taurus taurus is a
an earth sign i think yes um because he
sounds like a water sign
wait actually yeah an earth an earth
sign yeah
which is his true identity which you
will know if you know his birth time we
can find out what's interesting
to me is that like every long
relationship i've had it's like okay
let's say australia's not real or
whatever
then how come like for some reason
yeah then why why do virgo men love me
so much
well my longest relationships have been
virgos like my last
five year one was a virgo and then
steve's a virgo and they just like
i don't know it's like i'm like this
like water and then they're like this
like steady like earth like i can just
crash my waves on them they're like
whatever
like and they then they give me a hug
after and it's fine
whereas i dated an aries guy and then
he's like what you mean this and i'm
like crash my water onto his fire and
then he's
drying up all my water with his you know
whatever
there's two fire signs it burns down it
[ __ ] converts to get on like a house
on fire
remember it burns down
well or or you have a lot of power as a
couple
like if both people are larry yeah if
both people are like willing and want to
be in that relationship you're a
powerful
couple oh i can't think of a fire sign
couple but i'm sure there's like a
badass one
tight yeah neat i've never dated fire
though so i wouldn't know
you would or haven't i i haven't i and i
don't think i will at this point yeah
what's early september
uh yeah yeah who's a virgo
i think dad oh isaac's dead
i don't know so long ago it was like a
lifetime ago
but it was not a very fun experience you
could look up all those things too they
have like compatibility things and
it's weird when it lines up it's like
okay
i'm about to read something it doesn't
matter i'm about to hurt my feelings
tonight let's call when he doesn't cry
goddammit
i did ask for example diana when she
read my birth chart i was like oh like
what do you think is a good day like
sign today because i was like i did this
i did that like they're all
it doesn't work out and she did tell me
that cancer men are really good because
they tend to be softer and they tend to
be more understanding and i was like
okay so just put up with the water huh
and she's like yeah put up with the
water
they're kind of sensitive very much so
but once you understand that yeah
you're like i appreciate you for the
sensitivity you bring
as opposed to like it balances it out
yeah as opposed to somebody who's just
gonna like run over your feelings and
district argue
like a capricorn yeah oh wait what's
wrong with peppercorns because
it looks like a peppercorn
like if you like that you like that but
um they also are tend to be more
traditional so they like the they're
partnering to be more domestic you know
like traditional roles and stuff
i don't know this is all general
generalities
look up your own personal birth chart if
you want your details on your life
um and on that note please put in the
comments yeah and tell you and tell
us how you're saying about comments yeah
tell us how you feel about your sign if
you if you
agree with it and let us know if you
want us to bring stacy's friend diana on
the show
maybe i want to bring her i want to meet
her dad she's so cool she's in phoenix
right now but i'm sure we should
get out of here zoom in yeah zuma zoom
zoom episodes
and yeah like let's talk in the comments
let us know if you went to the birth
chart and
you were like this is [ __ ] and my
birthday's wrong or
if uh if it was accurate for you and did
you guess our signs right for those of
you who are into it
um are rising you probably are our moon
you probably thought we were our rising
signs because that's what we're given
the world
okay uh subscribe like us uh
comment go to stacy's instagram twitter
whatever youtube
this one i love your bracelet i keep
looking at it throughout the day and
this one
it's my jewelry shop you guys look like
a jewel yeah it's like my last name
thank you guys next time thanks for
coming we love you
bye